[music playing]
NARRATOR: Outside the
White House, the last hour
of the last day of World War II.
Here, and across the nation,
tense crowds await the end.
Inside, newsmen are
summoned to the president's
office to see history made.
I deem this reply a full
acceptance of the Potsdam
Declaration, which specifies
the unconditional surrender
of Japan.
In the reply, there
is no qualification.
Arrangements are now being
made for the formal signing
of the surrender terms at
the earliest possible moment.
General Douglas
MacArthur has been
appointed the Supreme
Allied Commander to receive
the Japanese surrender.
The proclamation
of VJ Day must wait
until the formal signing of
the surrender terms by Japan.
NARRATOR: Reporters make a
dash for official handouts.
Within a matter of minutes,
the historic news is flashed
to every country on the globe.
Meanwhile, New York crowds
have been waiting day and night
for word from Washington.
It is two minutes after
7:00, nerves keyed
to the breaking point by
last minute Jap stalling,
by rumors and denials that
surrender is on its way.
Then, the news
hits Times Square.
[cheering]
All the pent-up joy of five
days waiting is unleashed.
New York and Main Street
everywhere pulls out the stops
and lets go.
Yes, from coast
to coast, victory
gets a spontaneous welcome.
San Francisco, blacked
out and constantly alerted
against Jap treachery,
uncorks the pent-up emotions
of almost four years.
Market Street is a mad house,
but who cares on VJ Day?
In Seattle, Boeing workers,
builders of those giant B-29s
take some time off at last.
Downtown, at 4th
and Pike Streets,
they see sailors
lift automobiles,
soldiers kiss pretty
girls, a little trouble,
but only a little.
Then, the Navy takes up
the girl-kissing detail
and the carrying off
of beautiful maidens.
A marathon celebration, as
happy war-working Seattle
roars its tribute to victory.
The Midwest gives voice too.
At State and Madison, joy is
really breaking out all over.
And the jam-packed Loop
keeps it up all night.
Down south in Atlanta,
it's the same story.
All of north Georgia tries to
squeeze into Peachtree Street,
as people did in every
town in every state.
But VJ Day has a grim side too.
Wounded vets at Atlanta's Lawson
General Hospital hear the news.
These men know the
true price of victory.
For them, the war
will never end--
never quite.
But back in New
York, Chinatown casts
aside its usual quiet dignity.
Ritualistic dragons,
symbols of peace,
cavort along Pell
and Mott Streets.
Happy end to eight bitter
years of Jap aggression.
In nearby Mulberry
Street, Little Italy
makes with the noise and
dancing in the street,
a colorful corner of the
big-town celebration.
But it's at Times Square
New York really let's go.
Two million people jammed
into 10 blocks, and listen.
[commotion]
The Great White Way is itself
once more, only more so.
And this joyous din
keeps up all night.
But comes the dawn an
even blas  New York
seems to have exhausted itself.
[music playing]
But wake up their, son.
This war was big enough
for two celebrations.
And sure enough, the
entire show starts
all over again by daylight.
The kissing, the impromptu
entertainment, the biggest,
noisiest celebration
in New York's history.
Two days of needed popping off
before we face the realities
of peace in a world which
contains a new cosmic force,
the atomic bomb.
[music playing]